civil society
is one of those terms that you might
hear in a politician's speech
maybe in a line about the importance of
maintaining a strong relationship
between the government and civil society
but what does it actually mean
a society that's civilized
or maybe the part of society run by
civilians rather than government agents
in fact civil society is a little hard
to define
let's start with what it's not
it's not
government or elected officials who are
acting in their official capacity as
representatives of the state or nation
that is the political sphere
it's also not businesses or corporations
who exist primarily to make a profit
that's the economic sphere
and lastly it's not purely private
aspects of society such as family or
home life
civil society exists in between these
three spheres and includes all of the
non-governmental groups
associations and institutions that
citizens form and join
if you and your friends decide to create
a neighborhood cleanup club picking up
litter from the streets and planting
trees in the park congratulations
you've just joined civil
society some other examples of civil
society include religious organizations
professional associations
charitable groups
or interest groups
non-governmental organizations or ngos
are some of the most notable actors in
civil society
these include organizations like doctors
without borders
some organizations overlap a bit with
other spheres
labor unions for example are voluntary
organizations but they overlap with the
economic sphere by petitioning
businesses for better wages and working
conditions
ngos that have a humanitarian mission
like amnesty international may overlap
with the political sphere since they
petition governments to change how they
treat their citizens
some non-governmental actors are harder
to classify like the news media where
does it fall in civil society
it usually has some goal of making money
but it also helps inform citizens about
the workings of government and helps
hold politicians accountable to the
public so the media plays a central role
in civil society
so what's important about civil society
well all of these organizations help
connect people to their communities and
many of them strive to improve society
by influencing these spheres
often they're in conflict with one
another
but most importantly they show us that
there are many ways beyond voting or
running for office
to become involved in issues that you
care about